VISION FOR THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
THE SPIN, WITHOUT THE SMEARS.
JOINING US WITH REACTION,
DONALD TRUMP JR.
YOU ARE IN THE GALLERY.
YOU’VE HAD A BAD FLU.
ARE YOU FEELING BETTER?
YOU ARE A TRUMP.
YOU KEEP WORKING.
I AM A CONSERVATIVE, AND I
TALKED TO A LOT OF FRIENDS
DURING THE SPEECH TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE SPEECH THAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE WANTED TO
HEAR SINCE REAGAN.
MORE PEOPLE, INDEPENDENTLY
TELLING ME THAT THAN ANY OTHER
COMMENT I GOT TONIGHT.
>> I THINK IT WAS PHENOMENAL.
YOU COULD SEE IT, NOT JUST FROM
THE REPUBLICANS.
I GOT A LEG WORKOUT STANDING UP
EVERY FIVE SECONDS BECAUSE HE
HIT EVERY POINT.
WATCHING THE DEMOCRATS WAS
ACTUALLY WHERE I NOTICED IT
BECAUSE YOU COULD SEE THEM ALL
WANTING TO STAND, SEAN.
YOU CAN SEE THEM LOOKING AROUND,
LIKE WE ALMOST HAVE TO STAND FOR
THIS BUT THE DERANGEMENT IS
REAL.
THEY HAVE TO DO THE OPPOSITE.
THEY HAVE BEEN FORCED TO TAKE
THE OPPOSITE APPROACH OF
EVERYTHING HE DOES COME
EVERYTHING HE SAYS.
EVEN THINGS THAT ARE
COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS FOR THE
MERIT OF PEOPLE, THEY HAVE TO DO
THE OPPOSITE.
YOU COULD SEE IT.
IT WAS AMAZING TO WATCH.
>> Sean: RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
DEMOGRAPHICALLY, FOR BLACK
AMERICA, HISPANIC AMERICA,
WOMEN, 17-YEAR LOW.
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND SUCCESS.
HOW DO YOU SIT DOWN AND NOT WANT
TO CHEER THAT.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
SUFFERING THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
>> I DON’T KNOW.
IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE -- WHEN THEY
SEE THOUSANDS GOING BACK IN
THEIR WALLETS AND BILLIONS BEING
REPATRIATED, THE MONEY BEING
INFUSED IN THE ECONOMY.
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN BONUSES.
THIS WAS A UNIFYING SPEECH,
SPEECH TO ALL AMERICANS.
HIT EVERYONE DEEPLY.
IT WAS AMAZING TO WATCH COME
AMAZING TO SEE IT FIRSTHAND.
>> Sean: 2.4 MILLION JOBS.
200,000 IN MANUFACTURING ALONE.
2 MILLION AMERICANS OFF FOOD
STAMPS.
ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES, I
REMEMBER ONE OF THE FIRST
INTERVIEWS I DID WITH YOU, YOU
CALLED YOUR DAD A BLUE-COLLAR
REPUBLICAN.
>> I CALLED HIM A BLUE-COLLAR
BILLIONAIRE.
>> Sean: SORRY.
>> I USED TO GET CRITICIZED FOR
IT.
HE GETS THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHERE HE SPENT HIS TIME
BUILDING HIS BUSINESS.
HE DIDN’T BECOME A GREAT BUILDER
IN AN OFFICE.
HE BECAME A GREAT BUILDER BY
BEING ON JOB SITES, BEING AROUND
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO BUILT
THOSE PROJECTS, TALKING WITH
THEM, NOT AT THEM.
STAY WHEN I KNOW YOU’VE DONE THE
SAME THING IN YOUR LIFE.
WORKING IN RESTAURANTS, BEING A
DISHWASHER, COOK, BUSBOY, WAITE
WAITER.
IT CHANGED MY LIFE.
HONESTLY THOSE ARE THE AMERICANS
THAT HAVE SUFFERED.
>> THEY ARE THE FORGOTTEN
AMERICANS AND HE’S GIVING THEM
HOPE.
HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THEM.
HE IS AN UNLIKELY PERSON TO BE
ABLE TO BREACH THE BOUNDARIES.
THE BILLIONAIRE FROM
NEW YORK CITY BEING THE GUY, THE
VOICE OF A BLUE-COLLAR AMERICAN.
BUT HE CAN DO IT, AND HE DOESN’T
GENUINELY.
NOW THEY TOOK A CHANCE.
THEY VOTED FOR HIM, AND NOW THEY
ARE SEEING THE RESULTS.
AND IT’S AMAZING.
>> Sean: PEOPLE TRY TO ASK ME
ABOUT YOUR DAD.
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AND REMAIN
TODAY A REAGAN CONSERVATIVE.
AND I KEEP ARGUING WITH PEOPLE.
I AM NOT A NATIONALIST, NOT A
POPULIST.
I AM A CONSERVATIVE.
I LOOK TO THE LIST OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WE WILL PUT IT BACK UP ON THE
SCREEN, LIST OF PRINCIPLES FROM
JUDGES TO IMMIGRATION TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT ISSUES.
AND THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENED IN A
YEAR, THE HERITAGE FOUNDATION
SAID WAS MORE CONSERVATIVE THAN
REAGAN.
>> I SAW THAT COMMAND MORE
SUCCESSFUL BY THE NUMBERS.
FOR THEM, THEY WEREN’T EXACTLY
ALWAYS THE BIGGEST FAN.
FOR THEM TO COME AROUND AND SAY
WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS IS WORKING.
YOU SEE THE REPUBLICANS DO IT.
LAST WEEK YOU SOUGHT.
IT’S THE FIRST TIME THE
REPUBLICANS DIDN’T JUST FOLD.
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF BEING
AMAZING AT SNATCHING DEFEAT FROM
THE JAWS OF VICTORY.
THAT IS THEIR SPECIALTY, THEIR
SUPERPOWER.
NOW THEY HAVE SOMEONE WHO WILL
FIGHT FOR THEM, SOMEONE WHO WILL
BACK THEM UP AND GO TO THE WALL.
THAT’S WHAT’S BEEN INCREDIBLE.
NOW THAT THEY SEE THAT, I THINK
THEIR SPIRIT IS INVIGORATED.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE VOTERS WHO
VOTED FOR HIM, WHO ENTRUSTED MY
FATHER WITH THIS INCREDIBLE
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY SEE IT TOO.
>> Sean: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
DISTRACTIONS.
ALL OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAD
TO BE ACHIEVED IN AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT I WOULD ARGUE HISTORICALLY
UNPRECEDENTED.
HATRED, VITRIOL, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, LIES.
YOU YOURSELF -- I THOUGHT I WAS
TOUGH ON TWITTER.
I CAN’T COMPARE TO YOU OR YOUR
DAD.
>> WHEN YOU’VE GONE THROUGH WHAT
WE’VE GONE THROUGH, THE AMAZING
THING IS THE MEDIA, THE LEFT,
THEY WENT ALL IN ON THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THEY COULDN’T FIGURE IT OUT, HOW
COULD HE DO THIS TO OUR ANOINTED
ONE, OUR CHOSEN ONE WITH
ONE-TENTH THE MONEY AND     AND
ONE-TENTH THE STAFF.
THEY NEEDED THESE THINGS TO BE
TRUE.
THEY WENT ALL IN FOR THEIR
CREDIBILITY FOR THIS NONSENSE TO
BE TRUE.
WITHOUT EVIDENCE, WITHOUT
ANYTHING.
DESPITE 25 HOURS OF
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY,
MILLIONS IN LEGAL FEES, THE ONLY
THING THEY FOUND OUT WAS THAT
THEY THEMSELVES WERE THE ONES
DOING ALL THESE THINGS.
I REALLY HOPE FOR ALL THAT STUFF
TO COME OUT BECAUSE IMAGINE WHAT
HE COULD DO, GIVEN WHAT HE’S
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE LAST YEAR,
IMAGINE WHAT HE CAN DO WITHOUT
THIS FICTITIOUS BAGGAGE.
IMAGINE WHAT HE COULD DO IF HE
WAS UNLEASHED TO ACTUALLY FIGHT
WITHOUT THOSE DISTRACTIONS.
>> Sean: I SAY THIS OFTEN AND
I SPEND A LOT OF TIME.
IT WAS ABOUT A YEAR AGO WHEN WE
FIRST REPORTED ON THIS PROGRAM
WITH JOHN SOLOMON AND SARAH
CARTER THAT TRUMP TOWER, THERE
WAS A FISA WARRANT.
THERE HAD BEEN SPYING GOING ON.
NOW WE LEARN A LOT OF THE
BACKGROUND.
IMAGINE IF YOUR DAD FIXED THE
PRIMARY, HAD IT RIGGED AGAINST
16 PEOPLE, IMAGINE IF JAMES
COMEY AND OTHER AGENTS RIGGED AN
INVESTIGATION, EXONERATED YOUR
FATHER BEFORE ACTUALLY
INVESTIGATING HIM.
IMAGINE IF YOUR DAD DID PAY FOR
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA THROUGH A
DOSSIER AND IMAGINE THAT DOSSIER
WAS USED AS A FOUNDATION FOR A
WARRANT AGAINST HILLARY.
LET’S REVERSE ROLES.
YOU CAN’T EVEN FATHOM.
>> IF YOU HEARD ABOUT THIS STUFF
GOING ON IN ANGOLA, YOU WOULD
SAY THAT’S TERRIBLE BUT IT’S
HAPPENING IN OUR BACKYARD.
THIS ISN’T A BANANA REPUBLIC.
IT’S THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
FOR THIS TO BE GOING ON AT THAT
LEVEL.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THAT HIS DICTION
BECAUSE YOU HEARD IT TONIGHT.
MY FATHER IS FIGHTING FOR THE
GUYS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ALL
THOSE AGENCIES.
BUT THE BOOTS, NOT THE SUITS
THAT ARE THE LAWYERS OF THE TOP.
THEY ARE NOT THE SAME.
I WAS AT THE FLOOR LAST WEEK AND
I HAD 15 FBI AGENTS ACTIVE AND
RETIRED, TELL YOUR FATHER TO
KEEP GOING BECAUSE THOSE GUYS ON
THE SEVENTH FLOOR ARE TARNISHING
MY BADGE.
THE BLOOD, SWEAT AND TEARS.
THEY GET THAT HE IS STILL
FIGHTING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT,
FOR THE MILITARY COME ALL THE
THINGS HE PROMISED.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE BOOTS AND SUITS AT THE TOP.
THOSE SUITS, LAWYER’S INCOME OF
THE CORRUPTION IS REAL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, WHAT OTHER
CONCLUSION CAN WE DRAW THAT THIS
IS THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
EFFECTIVELY WEAPONIZING THE DOJ
AND FBI.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE THINGS HE
SAID TONIGHT THAT REALLY STOOD
OUT TO ME WAS FOR EXAMPLE PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT DISEASES.
MAYBE THEY HAVE BEEN GIVEN A
DEATH SENTENCE.
AND WE HAVE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY THAT PREVENTS PEOPLE
FROM MAKING CHOICES.
MAY BE THEY WANT THE RIGHT TO
EXPERIMENT WITH A DRUG THAT WE
ARE TOLD IS PROMISED --
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
>> Sean: NOTHING.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT, THE PEOPLE
BEHIND ME IN THE FREEZING COLD,
THEY DON’T CARE.
>> ANY CHANCE AT LIFE.
IT WOULD ENCOURAGE MEDICAL
DEVELOPING.
IT’S NOT ALWAYS GOING TO WORK
BUT WHEN IT DOES, THINK ABOUT
HOW FAST WE CAN EXPEDITE THOSE
THINGS.
GETTING OTHER PEOPLE THOSE
MEDICATIONS.
I RELATE TO THE BUILDER.
WE BUILT THE EMPIRE STATE
BUILDING IN THE YEAR.
NOW TAKES TEN YEARS TO GET A
PERMIT TO BUILD A COUNTY ROAD.
TEN YEARS TO GET A PERMIT TO
START, LET ALONE BUILDING IT.
THOSE OTHER REGULATIONS HE IS
CUTTING, THE NONSENSE, AND THE
LAYERS AND LAYERS AND LAYERS OF
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY.
WE DON’T NEED THEM.
THIS COUNTRY GOT TO WHERE IT IS
WITHOUT ALL OF THAT.
>> Sean: AMAZING STATISTIC.
I PRIDE MYSELF ON GIVING OUT A
LOT OF STATISTICS.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU HAVE HEARD A
FEW OF THEM.
BUT WHEN HE SAID THEY ELIMINATED
MORE BURDENSOME REGULATIONS THAN
EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT COMBINED
IN A YEAR.
GOVERNMENT HAS GOTTEN SO BIG, SO
BUREAUCRATIC.
BETWEEN THAT AND HIM TAKING ON
THE CULTURE AND TALKING ABOUT
THE FLAG AND TALKING ABOUT THE
ANTHEM AND
CHALLENGING THE NFL.
I THINK WHAT HE’S DONE, I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS THERE IS SUCH
FIERCE OPPOSITION.
HE’S BRINGING THE BUSINESS
ACUMEN SO WE CAN BUILD UP THE
COUNTRY.
THEY LOVE THAT CULTURE.
>> IT’S MADE THEM RICH.
IT’S MADE THEIR FRIENDS RICH.
THAT’S WHY THE BELTWAY IS THE
RICHEST PLACE IN AMERICA COME ON
THE BACKS OF THE AMERICAN WORKER
AND YET THIS AREA HASN’T CREATED
ANYTHING.
THEY DON’T BUILD ANYTHING.
THEY DON’T MANUFACTURE ANYTHING.
THEY DON’T CREATE ANYTHING.
THEY PEDDLE INFLUENCE.
HE IS GIVING IT BACK TO THE
PEOPLE, ALLOWING THEM TO USE
THEIR MONEY.
>> Sean: WHY DIDN’T YOU GO
WITH YOUR FATHER TO WASHINGTON?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
I CAN DO MORE ON THE SIDE.
I’M ALWAYS GOING TO BE ACTIVE
AND VOCAL.
>> Sean: OF ALL THE KIDS, I
THINK YOU HAVE THE SAME
TEMPERAMENT AS HIM.
>> MAYBE THAT’S WHY.
[LAUGHS]
AS AN AMERICAN AND THE FATHER OF
FIVE YOUNG KIDS COME I’M SO
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO WATCH WHAT
HE’S DOING.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY GROW UP
IN A IN AMERICA I GREW UP IN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ATTACKS ON
SO MUCH.
LOOKING AT THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY DON’T STAND UP FOR GOD.
THEY ARE RELUCTANT TO STAND UP
FOR THE FLAG.
THEY DON’T EVEN THINK ABOUT
STANDING UP FOR THE ANTHEM.
I AM WATCHING IT AND SAYING I
CAN’T EVEN BELIEVE.
TWO OF THEM DIDN’T.
THE VAST MAJORITY, RELUCTANTLY
I’VE GOT TO DO IT.
HE HAS TAKEN THE CULTURE ON AND
HIT THEM HARD.
>> Sean: THAT IS THE SWAMP,